you need a program just to keep up with
all the vacancies five general manager
slots available three coaching jobs i
don't know how many more are gonna pop
when the season ends presumably the
jaguars will add a coaching vacancy
presumably the jets will have a coaching
vacancy i don't know how many more are
going to hit the news from yesterday
first of all the new vacancy in carolina
marty herney will be out at the end of
the season as gm not a surprise
whatsoever i'm only surprised it took
this long david tepper's owned the team
for a few years now he made it clear
that he's looking to improve
the systems across the board and
hernia's a little too old school for
what tupper's trying to do chris and
then the news that jim caldwell
has interviewed with the texans for the
head coaching vacancy there's a little
cart before the horse i'm a little
nervous about this i i continue to look
for more and more evidence of
dysfunction in an organization that has
been quietly commandeered by jack
easterby what are they doing
interviewing coaches when they don't
have a gm
that's what i'm confused about that does
not really make sense to me either i i
don't i mean it's it's uh
it listen
at the base level it just makes it looks
like the texans are just trying to kind
of get the rooney rule you know
exemption out of the way that's what it
looks like to me you know at this point
with yeah no really you know rumor of a
formulated game plan or anything like
that hey jim caldwell's in whatever
we'll see i don't know i mean jim
caldwell has been wrong so many time
wronged i hope i got that right so many
times in his nfl career it's
disrespectful it really is but uh yeah i
don't know and i don't trust the texans
either you're right mike
here's my sense and and look i i haven't
talked to coach dungey about this and i
don't want to make any unfair
assumptions but dungey is a big believer
in jim caldwell and dungey's one of the
advisors to cal mcnair and the search
committee it very well may be it was a
simple kind of semi-formal
just get to know him just get to know
him just be ready to go for when you
have a gm and maybe he should be a
candidate he's 62 and 50 as a head coach
yeah and as we pointed out last week
john gruden is 63 and 78 since winning
the super bowl 18 years ago so caldwell
has done well he's taken a team to a
super bowl he had the lions at back to
back nine and seven years even though he
knew that bob quinn who had been hired
as gm was ready to bring in matt
patricia that's what quinn wanted to do
from day one
and
in hindsight he probably should just
should have just done it from day one
instead of keeping caldwell but now
caldwell gets an opportunity i'm just
very concerned about what ultimately is
going to happen in houston where will
the reporting lines be does the coach
report to the gm does the gm report to
the coach they independently report to
the owner where's jackie used to be in
all of this those are all questions i
would have going forward the best
selling point though is they have desean
watson
definitely and that's where it's gonna
have to be all about him really i mean
what what are you gonna do to continue
to surround him with talent you know and
okay what are you gonna do is that head
coach gonna be some offensive genius are
you gonna do an eric b enemy or a brian
dayball who's a hot name out there like
that or are you gonna go the defensive
coach but if you go the defensive coach
then he better have a plan of hey i've
got this offensive coordinator waiting
or this guy to come in here to be my
offensive coordinator going to be very
important but watson's going to make
that job a lot more appealing
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports